Mặc là buông dễ bị tổn trời dây nắng
Bùng nếc khổ chăng gần nguyên tốc vừa mắt bử đếp
Danh nơi vứa trên nắng mặc không chơi chánh ký
Sa mặt không chỉ sạm đi
Mặc không dễ bị lạo hoa sớm
Tì vậy đã để lúc nơi cất chức khổ chăng bắt năng dùng
Bặc không còn là chức khổ chăng vải tổ tuần
Phong chăng trong tuần về chức luộc băng nhảo
OK, chính là là chắn này mại
Súc bảo vệ lần ta khỏi tiêu tím
Bột đi và cạnh nơi đây gái
Một đi tế tả tỏ, ốc trọt tỏ, tỏ, mụ khôn mặt
Chế phụ kỹ từ gần mà để tâm sư kinh nắng cải đất mùa hẹn
Phu hợp chứng ai thử xuyên phè dí trên ngoài trời
Phó chí đất sản là một vĩ trời ra mặt luôn quay mạnh
Vìm cộng lần nhất chính là chất liệu vụ mặc mắt lại
Sau vào là thêm miệng, đều lên là thêm khoảng
Vừa khi mặt nguyên bật sợ tự
Không về đi ra, lý tự trên nước này hẹn
Oìa, về đều cực em
Không làm đau tay kể cả đều tìa xa đi châu
Mỗi xanh pham được hành lệnh kỹ lớn bên đi
Sất nhiều lần và khôn vài rau
Họ đồ mâu xác nhẹ nhàng sẽ phù đồ
Dá thì chỉ bằng vụ đi chả sớt
Nhưng công tục thì đất sớt săm nhiều
Tổng chỉ đánh tiêu cho chị em đông nhé
Tên là một đồ cho các ra đình ủc ai dù tự mê
Vừa đẹp vừa mắt lại mặt luôn
Chọn chí trên vua này tảy